Mexico has exploded in outrage over the
43 students who went missing at the end
of September in the town of Iguala now
according to authorities local police in
the state of Guerrero arrested the
students and handed them over to a drug
cartel who killed them incinerator their
bodies and dumped them by a river the
students were from a rural Teachers
College called a Yahtzee Napa the word
on everyone's lips in the streets and on
social media latest revelations about
ayotzinapa I want to cry a government
that kills his students is a government
that kills its country hashtags includes
somos todos IOT Napa we are all yochi
Napa and EPN bring them back a call on
president Pena Nieto to take action and
demands for him to step down with
renunciate p.m. Nieto has addressed the
incident but new revelations didn't
interrupt his trip to China Manolo
Serrano says let him go to China if you
come back Enrique Pena Nieto Mexico
won't be the same submissive country
that you left the students were
traveling through the state of Guerrero
when police opened fired on their buses
killing three of them three bystanders
and arresting those who didn't manage to
escape 72 people have been arrested in
connection to the killings including the
mayor of Iguala and his wife who
actually tried to flee no wonder because
according to Mexico's Attorney General
the mayor himself ordered the attack to
try and prevent students from
potentially interrupting an event that
his wife was hosting discussing thugs
who followed orders from discussing
rulers then after revealing the gruesome
details of the murders Attorney General
Marie o stopped the press conference he
was giving with the phrase young I can
say I'm tired or I've had enough
shouldn't have said that
young I can say is now a rallying cry
for the movement demanding justice for
the students I've had enough of the war
on drugs I've had enough of them taking
us for fools one wall in Mexico City
reads I've had enough of the
MX Apple tweets yarmulke sa is not just
for IOT napa it's for the whole nation
exhausted and fed up with demagoguery
impunity and the arrogance of the
Mexican government there have also been
solidarity protests and gestures from
around the world and the UN and Human
Rights Watch have both condemned the
killings in a country where well over
60,000 lives were lost to drug violence
in just six years and 20,000 have
disappeared it's not only Mexicans but
the whole world that is watching and
wondering when it will all end
you
[Music]